these really huge it's that time
[ __ ]
what's happening [ __ ] time to
tell your boss to suck your dick you're
taking a walk outside hang out with
y'all go Joey beers it's a beautiful
[ __ ] day they'll be alive the
birds are chirping the Sun is out and
even if the Sun wasn't out you still got
a sling dick with doing so it doesn't
really [ __ ] matter we pull the [ __ ]
ain't gonna lie to you [ __ ]
today is not the best reef a day of it
for me I forgot yes there's space down
and go over and see the [ __ ] jewel
today I got some of that [ __ ] [ __ ]
over some of this vegan from butter
Rosa's not the best reason not my type
of [ __ ] grief or not the reflex when
I make you see the devil and make you
hear voices and people yelling and
people getting shot you know I like
smoking reefer and it seems like in your
mind it's like a scene from [ __ ]
novels and they blow up the wedding and
[ __ ] like that that's what you want in
your head that's real [ __ ] reefer this
this'll do you know they'll kick your
eye for an hour or so
but it ain't what problem Joey's useless
done but it doesn't matter once 10
o'clock comes I'll be at the Reed store
you understand me from there I'm on a
jujitsu
do a couple kettlebells do a little take
fat attack fit whatever the [ __ ] it is I
got a [ __ ] conference call at 10:00
this morning I'm not a thousand [ __ ]
things on my plate but it don't matter I
always got time for my favorite [ __ ]
nephews you understand me nephews and
nieces [ __ ] uncle if I don't see you
[ __ ] that ate the malt is
sparking up a number tell me how am I
gonna [ __ ] get him
but Joey enough with the chitty-chat
[ __ ] spark that [ __ ] number you
understanding a it's Wednesday right the
rest is up to you swinging dick given
how [ __ ] bubblegum and serving cocked
our [ __ ] mode or fried Diablo
whatever the [ __ ] they prefer that's how
you do you serve that up today you don't
give a [ __ ] it's the last quarter it's
[ __ ] September 7th it's a beautiful
day in Cuba today it's fear birthday de
la vie hey never a lot today and
tomorrow is tomorrow like Ali Ali goalie
understand me that's that's why I run
with but anyway it's a complete
different story I like candles and cut
off chicken heads and do all that [ __ ]
but that's domani tomorrow as the
italian say
there's nothing like getting together
with you [ __ ] at 8:15 in the
morning and sparking that's what that's
what it's all about that's what America
is all about freedom getting together
with your [ __ ] boom Bosma saying you
know what whoo sparking [ __ ] one down
one tube to dope I'm talking you back as
soon as I go with that conference call
pick up he called me two days ago he
said he's got some [ __ ] weed he is
worried if I gonna said you got pushing
the [ __ ] here
that's what I want I want the weed you
could you got punched in the [ __ ]
here Labor Day week it's a little dead
people at home counting their [ __ ]
pennies I don't give a [ __ ] and come out
all week I was out last night at the
Dark Horse and reseed if you came by I
love you that's our usual man on Tuesday
nights we go up there so I can open mic
read some muscles some s'mores Matt
laughing comes out my big bad shame Bert
Kreischer [ __ ] wolf Felicia James and
[ __ ] jujitsu just a bunch of guys
getting together no drama no industry oh
my god is is there an agent to you who
gives a [ __ ] will you [ __ ] stand up
got some number two cuz I got [ __ ] to do
and people are [ __ ] see tonight you
understand me let's see what this will
work like I said this is regular weed
for regular [ __ ] people oh my god
that smells something this is [ __ ]
garbage this ain't the [ __ ] I usually
soon
this should I usually smoke when I open
up the container says don't do it
[ __ ] here we are man who's
better than [ __ ] us we get together
in the mornings we smoke a [ __ ] bulb
and you know what the best thing about
it they gets tapaswi like [ __ ] like
[ __ ] herpes is the freedom This Is It
this is what Thomas Jefferson is shut
that [ __ ] do for the [ __ ] day and
for the future
Wow nobody that's [ __ ] who a podcast
either clump to church eight o'clock
tonight tomorrow night my 15 flap is no
expectation stool workout material ten
bucks to get in
and Friday [ __ ] Saturday unlike the
Melrose improv are you kidding me on
what reefer the Agostino Lisa yeah stars
the debts will [ __ ] going deep and
guess what it's an eight o'clock show so
yeah out of there by Tannen you slingin
picked by 11:15 that's how I roll I put
you in good [ __ ] positions and I'm
late and then the girl Frances been
tired then she goes home and you get
into an argument did you want to sling
dick but no no this is made of cloth
let's do one more like I said this ain't
[ __ ] we don't do it's finished I know I
lost two canisters a death - big [ __ ]
buds I don't know what but um I got too
[ __ ] high this is why I never get a
high in I just [ __ ] cousin you gonna get
high I got to find it I got to [ __ ] I
can't find it so what the [ __ ] but the
special October 15 Willie boy Santa's
help me craft this [ __ ]
I'm doing things I never did before you
know because I got you guys watching man
I can't let your mother [ __ ] down
that's the most important thing that's
always been the big thing in my life
I'll get the believing you can't let
them down period I don't give a [ __ ]
about anything else that's the most
important do you want to let those
people [ __ ] know that you're a
bathroom right I somebody goes to bat
for you you have a work double hard you
got to get that a quarterly you have to
leave at five [ __ ] Garrity you just
can't be one of the regular people you
gotta prove me correct so that's the
lesson today
I'm not sitting that's that it's that
simple I keep a [ __ ] simple you write
your goals you go out and [ __ ]
execute and you come home eat a little
something you go to bed you do it again
the same day to the [ __ ] tea to the
[ __ ] teeth everybody wants to do
something for 90 days and they forget
about now I wasn't working I then worked
out cuz you didn't give it a chance to
put them work out you know and you
imagine if I were to tap down there
would have been no Paris go there women
know nothing you can't do periscope from
[ __ ] prison Jack so did you [ __ ]
together
it's the final corner that's it
it's a temp October November December
that's it you're [ __ ] dead you're
back to square [ __ ] one you don't
lend them another year I'm not ready yet
well you're always ready you're always
ready when you get the Vietnam those
people weren't ready just drew him out
of a [ __ ] helicopter they landed on
the [ __ ] island filled with [ __ ]
you know some PT Mao and [ __ ] like that
so you're always ready don't let them
[ __ ] hold you back you're always
[ __ ] ready
sorry about anyway
couple things I seen you [ __ ]
tonight about 7:25 7:30 get the party
started some [ __ ] edibles some [ __ ]
reefer it'll be a celebration on a
Wednesday night remember what I told you
don't let nobody [ __ ] with you
thank you serving [ __ ] fried Diablo
today and you're the baddest
[ __ ] out and they can't stop you
all right I didn't mess that I did get a
little high I know a lot of you people
but stay black we'll see you tonight
7:30 8 o'clock